le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
le département chef de file de l'action
sociale s'engage pour l'insertion
professionnelle des réunionnais depuis
janvier 2016 un nouveau type de contrat
le contrat initiative emploi permet aux
chômeurs ayant des difficultés sociales
et professionnelles d'accéder à l'emploi
dans le secteur marchand daisy chercher
du travail depuis dix ans elle vient de
signer un celui-ci yeux et hôtesse de
caisse depuis quatre mois
[Musique]
alors là je me rends sur mon lieu de
travail
comme je viens de la chaloupe saint-leu
moi comme tous les matins daisy effectué
les 45 minutes de trajet qui la sépare
de son entreprise
la jeune femme est hôtesse de caisse
depuis quatre mois dans un supermarché
au port à 31 ans c'est son premier
emploi fixe fait
[Musique]
par hasard on va dire à mes heures
perdues je suis chanteuse et il
recherchait des chanteuses pour faire
une petite prestation et du coup je suis
venu voilà je me suis présenté
j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire et par
la suite je me suis dit pourquoi pas
demander s'ils recrutent
[Musique]
avec un niveau bac
daisy a enchaîné les formations et les
petits boulots pendant des années à la
base
je ne voulais pas trop travailler dans
le commerce mais au fil du temps après
mûre réflexion
ça me plaisait bien j'ai deux filles une
de six ans et une de 11 mois je les
élève seule il faut maintenant dei
bénéficie d'un contrat de type c est ici
yeux les contrats initiative emploi vise
les publics en difficulté sociale et
professionnelle
c'était vraiment une opportunité pour
moi de m'insérer dans la vie active
et puis d'avoir un travail fixe surtout
on sait que à la fin du mois on a quand
même un salaire pour pouvoir subvenir
aux besoins votre ticket en 2016 2000
contrats de type c et 8 c ie ont été
signés à la réunion c'est un contrat qui
est en contrat aidé il a quelque chose
d'original c'est que c'est pas un
contrat aidé ou la collectivité
vancaille est jeune c'est un contrat
aidé qui va chez le secteur privé ce
jeune garçon ou cette jeune fille il est
dans un vrai emploi qui correspond à un
besoin et donc qu'il ya des possibilités
1 d'expérience et surtout de
pérennisation du contrat donc c'est un
dispositif qui est important parce
qu'ils misent sur le secteur marchand le
secteur privé on sait que durablement
c'est lui qui crée la richesse et c'est
lui qui crée l'emploi pour les
entreprises le système est plutôt
satisfaisant notre effectif du groupe on
a deux points ça fait pas mal
des gens ça fait déjà deux ans qu'on
confessé jean contrat d'une part ce que
notre entreprise en a besoin d'eux
les gens compétents et
motivé notre premier but c'est de donner
la chance aux gens et surtout les jeunes
je suis à tous qu'on a un niveau 2
de chômage c'est important pour inciter
les entreprises à jouer le jeu
l'état et le département finance une
partie des charges de l'emploi aidé
entre 10 et 40 45 2
charge donc ça se met en place avec le
pôle emploi on envoie des demandes
encore des postes bien spécifié
s'ils désirent elle a forcé le destin
c'est grâce à ce système qu'elle a pu
tenter sa chance
[Musique]
c'est tellement difficile de nous et
puis moi ce qui clochait beaucoup
c'était mon âge
[Musique]
pour la jeune femme cet emploi est une
aubaine rien ni la distance ni la
fatigue montage sa motivation et sa
bonne humeur sa le contact avec les gens
parfois on a le temps de discuter mots
très rapidement et puis mince et le fait
de de redonner le sourire aux gens mais
tu es obligé garder mais après quand on
dire au sort de la fève 48 euros et 23
centièmes s'il vous plaît c'est mon
premier vrai travail et j'en suis fier
voilà bonne journée
[Musique]
les contrats initiative emploi sont des
emplois aidés dans le secteur marchand
en 2016 2000 contrats de ce type ont été
signés sur l'île laisser hui c est eux
s'adresse aux personnes sans emploi
rencontrant des difficultés sociales et
professionnelles jusqu'à 47 % du salaire
de base peut être prise en charge
pour plus d'information vous pouvez
consulter le site du département au
www.cglpl.fr
[Musique]